policy
but also on trade and research just to
name a few areas
and in times of crisis cooperation
becomes even more important and this
applies not least for our international
defense partnerships and sweden's
partnerships with the uk and with nato
have been crucial during these
exceptional times
and i greatly appreciate
the strong support your government has
expressed for
our security and our right to make our
own security policy choices
and today we are taking another step to
strengthening our bilateral defense and
security cooperation at the strategic
level
and i'm very happy that you have come
here today for the signing of our
bilateral political declaration of
solidarity
and the prime minister and i have agreed
to face challenges in peace crisis and
conflict together
and if either country should suffer a
disaster or an attack
the united kingdom and sweden will
assist each other in a variety of ways
the support will be given on requests
from the affected country and may
include military resources
the lecturation serves crucial purpose
regardless of the choices sweden will
make in terms of our security policy in
the future
and president putin thought he could
cause the vision
but he has achieved the opposite
we stand here today
more united than ever
and with the ambition of strengthening
our bonds even more
and the russia russian aggression
against ukraine
has been met with incredible bravery
from the ukrainians and the ukrainian
leaders
but also by a unanimous condemnation and
firm response from the entire
transatlantic community and
beyond and i look forward to continuing
our close cooperation and our bilateral
relations but also on robust actions to
put pressure on russia and support in
support of ukraine so please boris the
floor is yours well thank you very much
prime minister anderson thank you
magdalena and thank you for having me
your absolutely beautiful harpson
retreat
breathtaking and great to be back in
sweden and great to see you again
this week many of us have been paying
tribute to the brave men and women who
secured victory and peace
in europe 77 years ago and so it's a sad
irony that we've been forced to discuss
how best to fortify our shared defenses
against the empty conceit of a 21st
century tyrant
when europe celebrated ve day in 1945 a
victory that was of course
in those small part ensured by the
heroism of the russian people
we hoped that peace on our continent
would endure
well putin's bloodthirsty campaign
against a sovereign nation
has put an end to that hope and we face
a new reality
but one that we face together
throughout this conflict our nordic
partners have been leading international
support not just for ukraine but also
for european security
from sending defensive weapons and
equipment to bringing together
international partners and standing
shoulder to shoulder with us in the un
uh the human rights council
the icc the international criminal court
the war in ukraine is forcing us all to
make difficult decisions
but sovereign nations must be free to
make those decisions without fear
or influence or threat of retaliation so
i'm very pleased today with you uh prime
minister anderson
to sign this mutual security assurances
declaration
it's an agreement that brings our two
countries even closer together it will
allow us
to share
more intelligence bolster our military
exercises and further our joint
development of technology
the many carcasses of
russian tanks
that now litter the fields and streets
of ukraine
thanks to swedish developed and british
built end laws
certainly speak to how effective that
cooperation can be
but most importantly
this is an agreement
that enshrines the values
that both sweden and the uk
hold dear and which we will not hesitate
to defend and as you
put it so well uh magdalena when we're
out on the lake uh we are now literally
and metaphorically
in the same place
thank you all very much i think we're
going to go to the to the media now
good afternoon james landau bbc uh prime
minister johnson first can you spell out
very precisely for us what this mutual
security agreement actually means of
practice if russia were to attack sweden
what would the uk do and secondly if i
may is now really the time to have a
fight with european allies over the
northern ireland protocol at the height
of this crisis
and prime minister anderson if i may can
you give us your assessment of the
threat
against your country from russia and
what response you might expect from
moscow if sweden were to apply to join
the nato military alliance
thank you very much james
first of all let's be let's be clear
that the the friendship and the the
relationship between britain and sweden
is decades old and what we're
saying
and doing now is uh in some ways uh
no more than a statement of the the
obvious that two liberal uh democracies
uh faced with uh an attack upon uh what
one of the other uh would want to come
to each other's support and whether it's
uh in the event of a disaster or a
military attack what we're saying today
is that upon request
from the other party we would come to
the other party's assistance and it's
vital uh to state that i think now ever
more important to state that now in the
the grim circumstances in which uh we
find ourselves with the russian attack
on ukraine but it it's also
i think an important step forward
because this is a an agreement on which
we together intend uh to build uh
whether it's in uh sharing intelligence
or uh working together to combat uh
cyber attacks uh whether it's working
together in uh defense procurement
uh or or joint doing more joint
exercises together we're in the jeff in
the uh the joint expeditionary force or
or any other forum uh sweden and the uk
intend to do much more uh together and i
think the uh the n law uh
missile system really incarnates the
kind of uh closeness uh that uh that we
see in our in our relationship uh and
that's that's what this is intended to
underpin it's the foundation stone uh i
believe for uh for an important
development in our in our relationship
and on the uh on the on the the protocol
i you you've heard me you've all heard
me say this many times the the most
important uh agreement is the 25 year
old belfast good friday agreement uh
that
is crucial for the stability of uh of of
our country uh of the uk of northern
ireland and uh it's got a it's got that
means that
things have got to command across
community support plainly uh the
northern ireland protocol
fails to to do that we need to sort it
out
when it comes to threats from russia i
mean the tensions in this part of europe
and around the baltic sea has increased
during the last years given uh russia's
aggression towards ukraine also before
24th of february also the military
buildup of russia and also a more
aggressive rhetoric from from russia and
of course after the 24th of february
tensions are or even
even stronger
or more difficult than before
and
of course looking at the russian
military forces right now they are
rather occupied in in ukraine
if sweden decides to
send in an application to join nate so
russia has said that they will respond
but then exactly how they will respond
is unclear they have said that they will
increase their military presence in this
region if sweden and or finland sends in
an application
hello my name is family osborne we are
from swedish television um mr prime
minister
boris johnson
the question here in sweden is what kind
of aid
can we
expect if we were to be attacked in any
way during the transition process until
a full membership in nato can you
be a little bit more concrete on what
type of aid you will be sending if so
will you send troops to sweden for
instance
and to magdalena anderson how safe can
we feel today compared to yesterday
after this agreement that you signed
today thank you
well thank you very much and i think the
the the declaration really makes it
clear uh it's the it's upon request of
the uh of sweden the uk will of course
provide assistance but what matters
primarily is what what sweden uh decides
to to request and or what we're saying
is that uh we are long-standing friends
uh of sweden was uh where massive
partners and supporters of uh of sweden
we share the same ideals the same values
uh you know sometimes things
should go without saying but they're
worth saying
it's worth emphasizing that if sweden uh
were attacked and looked uh to us for
help and support then we would provide
it but it's up to sweden to to make the
request and and to spell out exactly
what uh support is requested
said are we safer with this declaration
yes uh we are of course this means
something and this is important whatever
security policy choice that we will make
in sweden if we want to join nato if we
decide to keep
outside nato this is an important uh
joint declaration but what is more maybe
even more important is the fact that
the prime minister is so engaged in in
the security of the northern part of
europe and you have taken such an active
role uh in this area and we are very
grateful for that and that also that you
are so clear that we do we share the
same values and we stand together
um good afternoon nina lloyd from the
press association firstly a question for
both prime minister johnson and prime
minister anderson will these um will
this declaration help sweden should it
decide to apply to nato in the period
after application but before accession
so-called grey zone and how
and secondly um prime minister johnson
the leader of the opposition has said
this week he would do the right thing
and resign if he's fined over
allegations of lockdown rule breaking do
you think that's the right thing to do
and are you acting dishonorably by
staying in number ten
well can i just say first on
on your
uh your question about
sweden and sweden's security um
uh the
uh
there's a separate conversation going on
uh here in sweden which i i don't want
to uh to get into it's a matter for for
sweden uh but what was saying
uh is about sweden's future relationship
uh with uh with nato that's a matter for
sweden but what we are saying
emphatically is that in the event of a
disaster or the inventive of an attack
upon sweden then the uk uh would come to
the assistance of sweden uh with uh
whatever sweden requested and uh we hope
that that's a useful uh an important
thing to say and certainly uh we regard
it in the uk as important for us that
sweden is saying the same thing to us
and uh this is a a mutual uh agreement
that uh i think is
an important stepping stone paving stone
as i said for developing our relations
in the future and on the on your second
question i think uh
well we've moved we've moved we're
trying to move beyond all that and i
think we're trying to focus on the
issues that really uh matter uh not
least the war in ukraine
um
i think this as i said this i think this
declaration is important whatever
security policy choice sweden will make
for the future uh but of course we are
right now exploring different options
and uh there are also discussions in
parliament between the government and
all political parties in in in
parliament and
of course we are exploring all possible
options and nato is one of them that is
on the table and during this process we
have therefore had discussions with
several countries on how they see about
how they see this gray period from a
potential application until we're
fully members
and
there we've had got reassurances from
several countries i had i'm here with
boris johnson today i had a press
conference with olaf schultz last week
and
i also had our foreign minister in
washington last week
mr johnson how strong is this
declaration of solidarity compared to
nato's article five would you for
example assist sweden with nuclear
weapons in the case of war
and
what if sweden in turn promised the uk
for this declaration
will this declaration
hold even if we do not join nato for
example or yeah we promise nothing else
yeah i think that's the crew that's the
really good question because i think
that in a way this declaration is
something that is uh about the uk and
sweden standing uh together affirming
our friendship and our our partnership
and our willingness to come to each
other's uh defense and support that's
what it is i think there's a there's a
separate issue about uh about nato which
which i think sweden is going to be
addressing in the course of the next uh
few days uh that's not for me to to
comment upon except of course to say
that uh i'm sure the uk will support
whatever a course of action sweden uh
decides to to embark upon and we'll be
as useful and supportive as we as as we
can
um
this is i think the this is about
our joint decision to show that we will
support and defend each other now when
it comes to uh our
uh
deterrent our nuclear deterrent uh
that's something we don't uh generally
comment upon uh but uh what i've made
clear
is that uh the
it's up to either party uh to make a
request and we take it very seriously
thank you very much
thank you
well uh there boss johnson and the
swedish prime minister magdalena
anderson uh speaking to journalists to
talk about their bilateral uh political
declaration of solidarity to each other
they will now assist each other
when they are invited to by the other
side this could include military uh
support as well and as the uh swedish
prime minister stated separate from
sweden's potential decision to try to
join nato let's bring in our security
and defense editor debra haynes in kiev
deborah as boris johnson said there um
it is a decades-old friendship this is
no more than a than a statement of the
obvious two
similarly thinking nations would help
each other but but how would you judge
the significance of what they've
announced today
it's really significant
in a short state short response and the
reason why i say that is because yes
sweden is not a member of nato like this
country ukraine ukraine isn't a member
of nato so when ukraine got invaded on
the 24th of february nato countries
didn't couldn't uh or didn't
automatically come to um to ukraine's
aid with forces on the ground because
it's not protected by this article 5
guarantee but what the uk has now done
in terms of sweden with this new
declaration of support is that if
before sweden if sweden does decide to
join nato before that
period of accession happens if sweden
were to come under attack from say
russia which is obviously the country
everybody's thinking about then it can
request support from the uk and the uk
has said it would respond to that
request including with military force so
then you could have a scenario where the
uk responds to swedish requests for
support with sweden under attack from
russia russia seeing that response and
then maybe attacking the uk in turn the
uk is a member of nato and so that would
then trigger an article 5 response it's
a bit complicated but it's significant
it does it obviously as the prime
minister
both prime ministers were saying this is
separate to any decision by sweden
whether or not to join nato but it is a
clear declaration of support and
solidarity between the uk and sweden and
as the british prime minister was saying
it shouldn't be a surprise they're
countries that share similar values that
have had a long deep relationship anyway
but setting it out so clearly at a time
like this when europe is feeling very
much under threat because of the actions
of vladimir putin it's an important
moment
deborah thanks very much
well let's just take a closer look at
why finland and sweden feel the need to
increase their security defense and
security analyst michael clark joins me
now and and we just have to look at the
map don't we michael the the proximity
and the size of the border between these
countries and
exactly i mean nato is an alliance of